here's more from sunny can you put the
warning up again and i should be
drinking today
uh this woman she's just extraordinary
so there was a carnegie mellon
university professor her name is ujja
anya
and she when the queen of england passed
away a couple days ago she put up a
really horrific tweet about it
and then carnegie mellon university put
out a statement saying that they don't
you know that she doesn't represent
their views now it's sort of hilarious
in a way as several people pointed out
online it's like well you let this woman
teach all these young people for years
so she can teach all these horrible
ideas but when she tweets out a bad idea
now we better say something about it
anyway surprise surprise sunny defended
her
what did he say he said she
she said a thieving raping genocide
empire is finally dying may her pain be
excruciating it was a thieving raping
genocidal um but i think
she went on twitter twitter took that
tweet down because it violated its
policies of of wishing
okay so first off she doesn't even know
if it's a he or she like she just
doesn't know what she's talking about
she's unprepared and everyone's the
worst of all things and that she can so
glibly yes it's just that the british
empire was just thieving and raping and
genocidal and it's like you know what
there were literally literally
millions of messages sent from some of
those places that uh people would say
the uk dominated and destroyed and you
know all of those things say india say
parts of africa in support of the queen
it's not to defend the empire and it's
not to defend people going outside of
their borders and imposing their wills
on people and any of those things this
was a woman
this is a woman who lived with really
incredible dignity her entire life who
was not supposed to be queen at the age
that she became it i mean it's an
absolutely incredible story uh the
abdication of the throne and her
stepping into these responsibilities and
she lived with grace and decency and we
can all talk about whether a monarchy is
worth it or not and in some ways i think
right now we're seeing proof that
monarchies have some value because they
last over time instead of just the the
crazed sort of politicking of the day
but okay putting all of that aside it's
just so incredible it's someone like
sonny yes yes she's genocidal and then
the monarch and it's all just evil